[Musique]
on n'est pas dans votre bureau là non on
est dans la salle à manger parce que mon
bureau je reçois moins bien le ça saute
bonjour daniel quand même bon jour en
quoi le numérique sera pour vous un
élément clé de la sortie de crise alors
je sais pas si c'est un élément de
sortie de crise je pense que c'est
surtout un accélérateur
des tendances actuelles c'est-à-dire que
quand on regarde ce que cette crise font
tout simplement elle empêche le face à
face et l'empêchent qu'on se voit et on
est obligé au fond de mobiliser toutes
sortes de technologies qui d'une
certaine manière attendait ce moment ce
moment où la distanciation social
deviendrait une règle et où la
communication avec autrui passerait
systématiquement par l'intermédiaire de
ses tablettes de ces sites de diverses
et variées et en réalité je crois qu'on
vit un moment tout à fait étonnant d'une
crise sanitaire qui est en train
d'accélérer les grandes tendances de la
transformation du monde depuis
maintenant plusieurs plusieurs années
peut-être décennies c'est vrai que
l'économie du numérique
explose dans la période les ventes de
tablettes d'ordinateurs jeff bezos le
patron d'amazon s'est augmenté sa
fortune a augmenté de 22 milliards
d'euros netflix ne parlons même pas
l'économie numérique s'est bien portée
jusqu'à présent qu'est ce qu'elle est en
train de vivre un véritable âge d'or en
ce moment de pause ou en tout cas
peut-être même le début d'un âge d'or et
il faut comprendre pourquoi elle est si
adapter à cette situation alors que nous
avons une manière
permettait de le penser l'économie du
numérique
c'est ce qui permet des bustes réaliser
la société de services dans lequel on
est entré on a quitté la société
industrielle depuis longtemps maintenant
on a longtemps parlé de sociétés post
industrielles pour caractériser le monde
dans lequel on était ce qui
naturellement ne voulait rien dire du
tout postindustrielle sa voulais juste
dire qu'on avait quitté le monde
industriel a fallu du temps pour qu'on
comprenne de quoi il s'agissait vraiment
et dans un de mes dix qui s'appelait il
faut dire que les temps changent et je
revenais
la prédiction d'un grand économiste
français qui s'appelait jean saura ce
qu'il qu'il forestier disait la chose
suivante l'humanité pendant des
millénaires à travailler la terre puis
pendant des siècles elle a travaillé la
matière c'est le passage d'une société
agraire à une société industrielle nous
entrons dans une période au cours de
laquelle l'homme a travaillé loeb loeb
lui-même c'est-à-dire que le propre de
cette société post industrielle
c est une société dans lequel on
s'occupe les uns des autres comme
éducateur comme aide-soignant comme
coach sportif comme si canellis voilà
l'idée qu'avait jean fourastié du monde
à venir il ajoutait deux choses la
première c'est que c'était un grand
espoir c'est le type de son livre le
grand espoir du 20e siècle enfin
l'économie allait être humanisée et il a
ajouté un codicille de plus ce qu'ils
étaient petit problème mais qui pour lui
dans n'était pas un cette société de
services elle ne va pas créer de
croissance économique pourquoi parce que
la valeur du bien c'est le temps que je
passe avec autrui je suis aide soignant
le temps que je passe avec la personne
malade c'est ça le bien en réalité que
je produis donc comme le temps n'est pas
extensible il n'y aura plus de
croissance économique est bien que fait
le numérique il est en train d'apporter
autre 10 mai une solution à ce problème
de fouras kg et il est en train
d'industrialiser cette économie de face
à face comment est bien en nous faisant
passer par les tablettes et autres qu'on
est en train d'utiliser ses délires en
numérisant les relations de face à face
en faisant vous soyez une information
que je peux traiter en faisant que en
cliquant sur quelque chose j'ai accès à
plusieurs clients à la fois peut-être je
vais entrer dans une phase où la
croissance va redevenir possible mais
une croissance qui n'est pas du tout
celle qui avait prédite pour acier une
croissance en réalité
déshumanisant mettons à distance le
prestataire et le client bref le type de
croissance que ce moment de confinement
rend propice en ce nouveau capitalisme
numérique dont vous parlez il irait
jusqu où on peut numériser juste coup on
peut numériser le monde est bien lui
pensent les gaffes à les gens qui
travaillent à la silicon valley les
spécialistes de l'intelligence
artificielle pense que tout peut être
numérisés l'intelligence humaine peut
être numérisés vos émotions peuvent être
numérisés
ce que vous êtes votre état de santé
peut être numérisés c'est peut-être une
des choses les plus claires
la médication à distance va progresser
dans des tablettes qui vont être
capables de faire un diagnostic avec un
médecin à notre goût très loin je ne dis
pas que le travail demain va
nécessairement disparaître mais la
relation de face à face va être réduite
à la portion congrue
il ya un film qui est formidable pour
comprendre ce qui se passe c'est le film
heure h vers le film dans lequel le
héros incarné par joaquin phoenix tombe
amoureux d'un logiciel et on comprend
pourquoi parce que ce logiciel est
merveilleux il a la voix de scarlett
johansson
il connaît tout de dieu héros il connaît
cette fente à ses phobies et qu'elle est
capable de lui chanter des chansons de
lui lui des récits de promener de temps
en temps il ya quand même besoin d'une
relation physique l'amour ça passe aussi
par le corps alors en effet pendant deux
heures une femme bien faire l'amour avec
joaquin phoenix c'est la voix de
scarlett johannson qui parle encore et
donc on voit que la relation de face à
face c'est vraiment le cas de le dire
est réduite à sa portion congrue et
l'imaginaire de ceux qui réfléchissent
eux monde de demain il est entièrement
habité par cette idée que les réseaux
sociaux valent mieux que les relations
de face à face que le télétravail puisse
devenir la règle on voit que c'est un un
fantasme évidemment et plus vous que
c'est à une dystopie on ne veut pas d'un
monde ce qu'on ne rencontre plus les uns
les autres mais vous savez le xxème
siècle c'est l'air d'une société
industrielle ou le travail à la chaîne
avait produit l'incroyable
déshumanisation du travail et n la
contrepartie avec des périodes de
prospérité
on comprend aujourd'hui que la
prospérité la croissance économique
d'ailleurs plus que la prospérité vient
avec un quantum de déshumanisation
confronté à ce même choix aujourd'hui et
on le voit évidemment le confinement
dans une forme extrême mais quand vous
dites ces gens qui se chargent au fond
de réfléchir au monde de demain à cet
imaginaire à ce fantasme de qui
parlez-vous je pense que c'est les gars
ça je crois qu'en effet ce qui est tout
à fait extraordinaire aujourd'hui c'est
que quelques entreprises qui vont
émerger d'une compétition darwinienne il
y avait beaucoup de candidats et peu
d'élus à la fin peut-être y en a
d'autres qui surgiront les netflix etc
je ne faisais pas partie du trio de tête
au départ et donc le jeu n'est pas
terminé mais ce qui est certain c'est
qu'il ya très très petit nombre
d'acteurs qui sont en train en effet de
définir le monde de demain et la
différence qui est inquiétant c'est que
avant peut-être d'une certaine manière
les innovations et des fêtes à
l'intérieur des entreprises
des ouvriers au fond on était à la
recherche d'une ergonomie mac optimale
dans avec encore une fois tout le stock
d'horreur que ça a pu vouloir dire dans
l'organisation du monde de travail mais
ça venait de l'intérieur des entreprises
cette recherche d'efficacité là ça vient
vraiment en extériorité c'est à dire
apple réfléchit à des google à toutes
sortes de manières de faire la médecine
autrement ça ne vient pas des médecins
ça ne vient pas des hôpitaux ça vient du
dehors donc c'est un monde proche de la
science fiction parce que c'est celui là
qui nourrit l'imaginaire deux de ses
acteurs de ces jeunes qui dans la
silicon valley cherche l'application
tueuse qui va remplacer les avocats qui
va remplacer les médecins qui va
remplacer les coachs sportifs qui vont
remplacer les agences de voyages voilà
cc c'est là que tout l'imaginaire de ces
nouveaux avantages se situe et et oui
l'état est souvent à la remorque est à
la traîne et moi je le regrette
profondément
j'aimerais que ce soit les hôpitaux que
soient les enseignants qui est la main
sur ces nouvelles technologies ce n'est
pas le cas aujourd'hui et pourtant après
fait créé vous le dit très bien on s'est
rendu compte qu'il y avait des métiers
essentiels des indispensables
alors on pense à robotiser les
caissières
on se rend compte de leur rôle aussi
fondamental dans le contact à quel
horizon vous vous situez ce potentiel
cette potentielle numérisation du monde
cette nouvelle économie de grottes c'est
maintenant déjà que ça commence déjà
quand vous rentrez dans un bureau vous
avez presque toujours la même scène des
gens derrière un écran d'ordinateur
il a été inventé dans les années 80 donc
on était à la chaîne dans les années
vingt et un suivi dans la société
industrielle d'après guerre aujourd'hui
on est en ligne donc c'est déjà le cas
qu'on est alors comment résister
d'ailleurs est-ce qu'il faut résister à
cette économie déshumanisant tout se
ferait à distance je crois qu'il faut il
faut résister il faut faire advenir un
autre monde si c'est possible je disais
il faudrait que les hôpitaux et la main
sur ces technologies pour bien optimiser
le rapport entre patients et le et le et
le et le soignant en voyant où sont les
besoins et on comprend qu encore une
fois qui est énergie peuvent aider à
faire les choses mieux mais mais sans
jamais briser le lien entre les deux
quand les enseignants aussi ont des
nouvelles technologies qui doivent
pouvoir utiliser peut-être pour changer
la manière dont il en scène mais
certainement pas pour casser le lien
entre les enseignants et les élèves et
beaucoup de choses et beaucoup de choses
comme ça donc il faut résister le
langage de mai 68 pour lutter contre la
société industrielle métro boulot dodo
etc je pense reste valide on voyait
qu'ils avaient une critique profondément
humaniste du monde industriel des années
60 qui malgré toutes les promesses de
richesse était considéré par la jeunesse
des sixties les hippies aux états unis
où les gauchistes en france comme des
humains dix ans et on a armé en quelque
sorte une critique culturelle manistes
artistes du set les sociologues du monde
hier il faut résister à ça il faut
résister à l'idée que tout se passe dans
les réseaux sociaux il faut résister à
l'idée que voilà on peut produire de
l'information sur ces réseaux sont
passés par des journalistes il ya un
petit travail un peu corporatiste de vie
différents métiers à faire mais qui peut
être révolutionnaire se disait bourdieu
il ya il ya quelques temps être
corporatiste par soi c'est c'est
résister à la moulinette de l'histoire
dans le bon sens justement alors résisté
aux gaffes à vous l'avez dit ça c'est
pour les géants du numérique du privé
parce qu'il ya évidemment des vrais
problèmes de libertés publiques et on
l'a déjà vu avant avant cette crise avec
la circulation des données personnelles
des états eux-mêmes
ont-ils d'ores et déjà ses data est ce
que les états eux mêmes peuvent
participer cette potentielle
surveillance généralisée où vous faites
économie du numérique alors si ses côtés
un des effets
j'espère pas pas mauvais de cette crise
sanitaire c'est vrai que quand on
parlait dans un ouvrage qui était publié
l'année dernière de capitalisme de
surveillance le point de départ de
l'analyse c'était de dire on est dans
une société de surveillance mais à la
différence des régimes de surveillance
anciens ce sont des sociétés privées qui
vous surveille et pour pousser un peu le
paradoxe la surveillance des régimes
totalitaires c'était pour vous empêcher
de vous exprimer c'est un peu la verse
on a un capitalisme de surveillance mais
qui veut que vous vous êtes premier
qu'il veut que vous sortiez toutes vos
lubies vos fantasmes et c'est pour
pouvoir justement vous offrir des
solutions à tout ça vous rêvez d'être
patron va vous donner
donc c'était quelque chose de très
différent de l'idée qu'on avait des
sociétés totalitaires même si elles le
sont parce que c'est du bio pouvoir pour
parler comme michel foucault et à lyon
vient vous chercher dans les replis de
votre intimité pour tout savoir de vous
maintenant avec la crise sanitaire les
états vont prendre la main sur ces
données aussi est un petit peu un débat
sur la question de savoir si les
applications qui vont permettre de
tracer les gens à proportion de nos
contacts on restait vraiment des données
privées dans les dents les dans les
portables ou si c'est un grand
ordinateur de l'état qui va permettre de
me surveiller les états comme la corée
otc d'état dans son grand serveur qui
sait ce que vous devenez ya une formule
que les gaffes en proposent il ya une
alliance apple google qui est celle avec
laquelle travaille l'état français pour
avoir une formule c'est dans votre
portable mais à ce moment là c'est le
portable c'est l'iphone qui allait
donner donc c'est les gars femmes
l'impression que on n'a pas d'autre
choix que l'état d'un côté ou les gaffes
à de l'autre pour ça que je plaide pour
une troisième voie celle dans lequel ce
serait les hôpitaux qui aurait les
données ce serait beaucoup plus
rassurant pour tout le monde je pense
que c'est ça la voix que les français
préféreraient est-ce qu'ils en sont
capables
je crois hélas que non il faut choisir
entre cette alternative l'état central
pas les hôpitaux qui est à son crâne
avec le numéro de sécurité sociale etc
qui c'est tout c'est pas la garde mittal
qui va être le le conte sport de ce
monde où les biens sans patrie sans
merci beaucoup daniel cohen ça fait
froid dans le dos mais c'est passionnant
merci beaucoup
[Musique]